black clouds soot dusty streets  the economy in this town like many  others across the eu  depends on coal mining but the people  living here suffer from the consequence  pollution immigration is  fund a plan to help industries regions  and workers  make the change from fossil fuels to  sustainable energy  parliament is asking for a bigger budget  for the fund which is part of the  european green deal  the plan for a carbon neutral eu  parliament would  like transition projects in vulnerable  communities to receive up to 85 percent  of their financing from the fund  [Music]  meps want support from micro enterprises  the mobility sector  new research and green infrastructure to  ensure that nobody is left behind  in the shift to a greener economy